havanna und willkommen zu sein will
nimmt ja ich weiß was ihr denkt schon
wieder pakete zum aufmachen aber diesmal
sind das ganz speziell aber boxen und
kein beauty also für die männer nicht
wegschaut weil ihr denkt jetzt kommt
wieder beauty lasst uns diese nicht
beauty box einmal auspacken die erste
box ist ganz speziell und zwar ist das
ein bücher wo also ein kinderbücher aber
und da musste ich vorher an geben für
welche altersklasse nicht das haben
wollte und da ich ein mädchen kenne was
sehr jung noch ist habe ich kenne ich ja
ganz kleine besteht
ich weiß mit der bücher box
60x gewesen geht thema kreativität sagen
ich könnte nie club lesezeichen haben
die pappenheimer kennt das jemand von
euch irgendwie sagt mir das was die
schriftgröße noch so großen seiten sind
so einzeln zu schön und all das ist toll
wollt ihr wissen was in dem buch
vorkommt unerkannt im gebüsch lädt das
geheimnisvolle volk der pappenheimer
mein zahlen wilder spaß ich weiss jemand
so gut erkennt aber wie soll man das
auswahl- und die felder sind richtig
winzig ja eine auswahl heft 17 590
bezahlt man vormonat und jetzt frage ich
mich aber dass weil die bücher ganz so
viel wert sind wie 1790 decker mit
pädagogisch wertvoll es ist eine schöne
sache wenn ich irgendwann kinder haben
werde ich bestimmt so eine super mama
sein die ihren kindern büchern schenk
und wir bleiben kreativ das ist die
superkraft box und elli schick dir
herbst kit 2015 zweifel diamanten vor
peeling fürs gesicht und körper ist so
eine bastel box mit so was du denn hier
gerade also mehr das salz würde ich mal
vermuten lässt lavendel glaubens kalin
form werde ich auf jeden fall für
weihnachten benutzen damit ich geschenkt
kennt ihr das nämlich das ist für eltern
und großeltern so so schwierig ist
geschenke zu finden was sie vom
fernseher aus
kaiser natron zitronensäure
lebensmittelfarbe blau fundort geil
orangenöl ja und ihr sensor
bedienungsanleitung wie man denn die
seifen und dinge alles gemacht was
kostet denn unsere schöne
superkraft box also wenn man zwölf
monate besteht kostet 24 95 im monat
oder sechs monaten bestellt dann 29
also es ist jetzt nicht das günstigste
aber ich muss leider sagen gleich gerne
wasser und welche dinge liebe dich echt
gut
alle links natürlich jetzt kommt eine
box auf die ich sehr gespannt bin das
ist nämlich wie grant news box halten in
the box sind lebensmittel drin die
irgendwie neukauf markt sein soll oder
ganz besonders toll greenteam mandarin
orange verliebten diese vermieten es
lustig seht ihr immer im supermarkt als
viel zu teuer es ist geil youtuber zu
sein es ist geil xt umsonst
damit kann man verlasse machen
aufstriche teil hab ich noch nie gelesen
warum weg viel stroh ja im herbst noch
grillsauce mitzuschicken ist interessant
grillsauce olade was ist also besonders
du arsch sonnig fruchtig und fruchtige
marmeladen noch mehr grillsauce hat
jemand von euch durch ok dann trinkt zum
beispiel neu knackig erdnüsse mit milch
und natürlich kräuter bouillon das hat
mich schon gefragt wo die sünde für
welches geld denn welches geld kostet
ist do 12 99 lohnt sich das ich weiß
nicht was die sachen 20 kosten aber
glauben es lohnt sich
texter lebensmittel muss nicht einkaufen
gehen nicht eine woche von barbecue soße
das ist nämlich eine vox schickt
cocktail zutaten und cocktail rezepte
mit damit dir jeden monat einen neuen
cocktail machen kannst du nur noch nicht
kennst und keinen alkohol horizont
erweitert nicht okay lasst mich kurz
schauen agricola muhle und santo spirito
sei die arbeit mit alkohol
okay was haben sich hier sehr fans dass
sie so cool aus dass ich jetzt schon rum
drin sieht auch ein bisschen aus als ob
die simple labor professor harry eine
liebestrank zusammenbrauen hausgemachter
inversion echt schlecht zuckersirup
hausgemacht ein innovatives piment
rahmen man das tut mir leid ich bin
nicht so der profi da sind aber es ist
alkohol und zucker sirup orange bitters
hausgemacht denn gute thomas henry so
what wo ist das rezept mit diesem
alkohol kann man vier mal den arrigo
kohle rudel machen merkte dass ich profi
bin
und zweimal den santo spirito natürlich
diese cocktails kenne ich doch ich
vermute aber schon dass es nicht ganz
günstig sein wird denn so ein alkohol
der nicht
der billigste ist kostet meistens auch
mehr wiederholt ab monatlich 35 euro
sagt die eine hälfte
ich treibe zeigt euch trotzdem dass
jetzt auch erstmal das letzte unboxing
die nächsten videos werden wieder mehr
experimente sein und mein stuhl